regardez les filles je vous présente les
à léa c'est une petite brebis doux et
sans elle est née le 3 mars 2018 avec
les cochons nains ce sont les stars de
la ferme pédagogique de cette 27e
édition du mai dessert éleveuse à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines hélène
guillemets venu présenter ses différents
animaux
j'essaye de les sensibiliser aux animaux
de la ferme leur expliquer leurs
habitudes leurs comportements comment
ils vivent ce qu'il mange comment les
aborder comme on les respecte et les
caresser les animaux lors il donnait à
manger c'était des pod et les idées des
optiques au chaud ils sont tous doux et
la ville sont très gentils
à côté des animaux de la ferme des
fleurs des plantes aromatiques et des
légumes toute la biodiversité réunis au
serre municipale de maurepas durant tout
le week-end
le but c'est de faire connaître aux
visiteurs toutes les méthodes qu'on peut
avoir pour jardiner entre autres
d'utiliser des paillages pour pas faire
de traitement parce que sûrement pas on
est au 06 tôt sanitaires plusieurs
milliers de personnes ont foulé les
allées fleuries du mais dessert le
rendez vous est pris au printemps 2010 9
pour de nouvelles aventures potagères et
animalière